ma con una colonna sonora così ma che
gioco mi potreste mai aspettare
vi faccio solo apprezzare la colonna
sonora di questo capolavoro perché da
questo voi dovete capire che titolo era
sto parlando di god of war
sto parlando di metal gear no
friscia out of water ed è
nientepopodimeno che questo però la
colonna sonora la bella pesce salta
rispetto al maggiore o il mouse bene a
più più click in più click in alto e tis
ordinata giustamente ve ne avevo capito
che si celi rimbalza sull'acqua nega che
si immergeva limbe rimbalzano se fosse
tutto va bene nel caso vi steste
chiedendo fa vj che cosa ne stai facendo
della tua vita beh non l'ho capito
neanche io ah ok abbiamo fitto tutorial
a quello era il tutorial bene già
partiti madonna più veloce di alonso e
dall'altra parte sempre l'altra
bellissimo sto gioco si of thieves po
compagna re solo serve una sorta di
getting over it se così vogliamo
chiamarlo solo che con un pesce no bene
piano piano ho pagato tutto
ma gag corsa due lo anche pagato sto
gioco non so dove devo arrivare non so
il perché ci devo arrivare ma devo
arrivarci ragazzini accompagnati in
questo viaggio porca eva n
non c'è verso di su questa montagna
porca vacca e la cosa ancora più comica
io ci spendo sempre dei soldi presso i
giorni se neanche me li danno gratis
no niente porca vacca non sanno fare
neanche le texture non sanno neanche
rendere una roccia solida e sto gioco
porca eva cava caccia fa schifo il gioco
almeno no no no no no la triste storia
di uno youtuber che spese dei soldi per
un gioco dove i pesci entrano dentro le
rocce ragazzi neanche gesù faceva sti
miracoli non ci arrivo porca eva è gesù
già essere arrivato che mi sembra un
miracolo incredibile quindi va bene
perfetto nome non aveva sbattuto come
facile andare avanti dicono scusate poi
ci arrivo lì sono ci arriva o
impossibile e vabbè pesce porca eva
paper pure colorato male c'è la
salmonella sto pesce deve essere il non
devi devi saltare due volte lo vedi che
porca eva schifosa di un salmone putrido
non c'è verso lo capisci guarda guarda
guarda guarda mariella reg
dai perfetto minchia un'ora per far sta
roba
c'è ma possibile il gioco putrido così
possibile ci mette un'ora fa una roba
così non ho veramente ve lo giuro un
raffreddore non so se si vede se si
sentono anche la febbre registrando
stupido con la febbre ok quindi non mi
fate girare le palle
ok
bene effetto perfetto ok che è che devo
aiuto amica quasta di vedrai ci sono
anche gli ostacoli qua
ok la madonna lavado e super mesto pesce
perico mezza come alzarvi al complimento
proprio dire far rimpiangere la vita sto
gioco impossibile alto fra un video su
qualsiasi roba tipo sul po che mondo non
sta roba
perfetto perfetto ok
bye bye bye fotte sei e cosa stai
andando vai radente effetto occhio che
quasi caschi ragazzi se casco qua non
voglio ritornare all'inizio non mi fate
ritornare all'inizio vi ammazzo seccato
qualche succede non lo voglio sapere non
lo scoprirò oggi non lo voglio sapere
by è un [ __ ] carrello
veramente no no no da mazzotta passo ok
perfetto di chiesto diventando un
fenomeno rega dovevo andare esattamente
qui chi sopra c'è una casa addirittura
dietro perché allora lo so io che sotto
qua ci sta di nuovo la barca e quindi
l'inizio tra capo lo so c'è bisogno me
lo dici mi disse non cadere fanno le
cose fatte bene che ho giocato talmente
tanta getting over in che soltanto che
siete così stronzi lamentarmi la barca
qua sotto
il problema è che non come dovrebbe
salire spiegami come si sa le qua no no
no no ok
ehi ed è no no no sono morto la nostra
mission incastrato in chiaro perché
adesso non mi posso neanche più muovere
quindi devo fare così quanti di voi
adorano il mio canale anche io amo il
mio lavoro mi piace un sacco fare lo
youtuber quando mi intervistano dico
sempre piacevoli youtube
sì mi dà mi ispira come lavoro mi dà un
sacco di gli sfoghi di sfogo cioè io
nella mia vita di tutti i giorni
magari sono stressato per registrare mi
sfogo non è senza poi mi libero corsetti
sterminarsi la famiglia di liberalità e
dai dai dai
mi ricordo neanche non mi ricordo
neanche voi ci sono arrivato lì pensate
come questo ho messo la forza forza
forza credeva daniels chi è se io dovrei
stare calmo quando hai la febbre devi
farti latisana rega dei fatti atti la
camomilla stai meglio porca eva gioco
sta roba mica domani mi sveglio che sono
in coma non cadere giù
ok come ho fatto ad arrivare davvero
prima non mi ricordo neanche faccia
schifo solo
ok lo so non so caduto tantissimo dopo
rimanere sotto le coperte guardarmi in
at least oggi che sono malato non era
una delle mie priorità miti ma poi
dovevo fare questa cosa di medico mi ha
detto gioca una roba che ti fa incazzare
che stai meglio perfetto barbara guerra
madonne web madonna ha tanto guarda
guarda niente tanto c'è resto proprio
non certo non mi dicono la gente poi no
ma bellissimo la gente ai raduni che mi
fa ma ce la farei a sconfiggere kit
mario
come se che mario fosse il mio nemico
numero 1 wyatt mario poi di gaza lo
conosce più quello era un tutorial in
confronto amiche ormai uscita della roba
che veramente se non lanci il mouse
c'è veramente roba che farebbe un altro
può bestemmiare papa c'è una roba
incredibile maastricht ma riva che mario
ma ma era una cagata che mare ma questo
era l'inferno
no no no non puoi avere la fisica su
certe robe non averla su altri stop esce
rimbalza sull'acqua c'è per farvi capire
che fisica delle palle e poi è poi
striscia se se cade più forte su io non
ho parlerò giuro cioè la fisica fatta
come vuoi per farmi incazzare è poi
passa attraverso gli oggetti perché non
questa merda tutte le cose ci sono
perché questa merda perché gioco di
pesce tutta dentro le cose non deve
entrare dentro le cose porca eva non
deve entrare ho speso dei soldi da temi
della qualità chris topo ed io la
grafica funziona la fisica funziona come
gli pare c'è nel senso come funzionano
male l'acqua mal di gola guarda sono
terre urlati in faccia che veramente
meriti di morire tutti quanti a prendere
due treni di fidarmi di pescina
perché